is it like moving as I'm now you're
looking at the picture headline God I
feel bad cuz it's like now people will
know how much time you spent on each
story this is ey tracking it's a
technology that's gathered attention
because of Apple's upcoming headset
release introducing Apple Vision Pro my
colleague called The Vision Pro
technology pretty insane especially
compared to other headsets out there so
what's possible with eye tracking right
now as you lean in then you can get
closer in more detail how does it work
so there's two sensors down here those
are the cameras and what are the
potential future use cases for people
that can't use their hands this is how
they interact with the
computer you navigate with your eyes
imagine a world where your eyes are the
remote control that world isn't far away
Vision Pro will be Out Of Reach for most
priced at a hefty
$3,500 but it appears to have some
powerful Tech you can navigate to things
with your eyes use your fingers as a
mouse FaceTime with other people's
realistic avatars floating in your room
The Vision Pro launches next year so
we'll have to wait like everyone else to
get our hands on one but ey tring
technology in some form has been around
for years and one of the leaders in the
space is the Swedish tech company Toby
where you're fixating how long you're
fixating in like an advertising context
that could be really important you have
two monitors two screens
no but I'm oh so you see yeah working on
this screen working on that
screen the company sells a gaming ey
tracker and IT Supplies technology for
Microsoft laptops HTC headsets and
others out of the company's existing
products Toby's PR glasses 3 for
businesses is most similar to Vision
Pro's Hardware here's how it works first
because these devices need to work in
dark environments both the Toby glasses
3 and The Vision Pro have led
illuminators here and here that can
expose your eyes in the darkness you
need tiny cameras to capture eye
movement two cameras per each eye
looking at the eye so four sensors there
and then yes one point of view camera
and then we can take the data from the
sensors and transpose it or trul right
on that so we can see what you see and
that's where Apple has come up with some
unique features first off it comes with
vision o an entirely new operating
system for Apple to click on things
you're looking at all you need to do is
pinch your finger
external cameras capture your hand
movements and translate those into
button presses on the screen all that
suggests that the Vision Pro will be one
of the most immersive experiences
available on a
headset but itracking technology extends
Beyond gaming and VR into feels like
marketing and research sort of gives you
more unbiased information about what
people prefer there's talk of it being
an essential component in the automotive
industry in fact in the European Union
there is legislation that's says that
starting in 2026 new cars cannot be put
on the road if they don't have camera
based driver monitoring systems what are
the privacy considerations if you know
you have information about what I'm
looking at what I'm focused on our view
of course is that in general as a
technology industry we need to be very
transparent with users of what it is
you're collecting and for what purpose
and I think if we do that the right way
we can get the value that it tring can
build uh can bring while the technology
is continuously improving there's still
a margin of error experts say selecting
tiny objects present some challenges
also not all eyes are the same when Toby
was form 20 years ago they built their
first eye tracker in 6 months but then
they took it outside Sweden and they
realized that the eye tracker didn't
work for people whose eyes was eyes
weren't blue whose eye shapes were
different and so we've spent a lot of
time looking at how these algorithms can
be robust across population what if one
day rolling your eyes lets you skip to
the next audio track or to the next you
video I'm thinking about my
editor yeah it'd be great to see what
he's thinking when he's editing my
[Music]
stories